you
hi everyone it's Jerry I have another
cool chess puzzle to share with you this
one is the work of two composers Philip
Bondarenko and Marc Luber can put their
minds together and produce this one in
1950 it's white to move feel free as
usual to pause the video maybe step away
for some time from the video and set
this one up on one of your own boards
spend some time with this and we'll see
if he can find its solution alright
first things first
this Knights under fire he needs to pick
a square and his options are down to two
he needs to be in a position to next go
to f3 and sacrifice himself for this
pawn that's just a step away the correct
square to go to is h4 this is the first
key move going to e one would subject
the knight to pressure by the bishop and
there's no reason to allow this valuable
tempo so after Knight to h4 King g1
Knight f3
that's a fork and now we have Knight
takes pawn
King takes night and from here the next
key move is to simply push the pawn now
in reply let's first consider the move
Bishop to one of these three might as
well just go one step don't want to
let's say get in the way of the king
throwing a punch at the bishop for
example if you went to d4 let's just say
Bishop to b2 preparing to stop the pawn
once he's on e6 let's see what would
happen after Bishop to b2 b6 the bishop
must go here to stop the pawn and now
the King at this point makes a run he
races towards the a7 pomp King e5
there's no way to improve the bishop so
it's time to improve the King
King g3 King defies king of for King c6
king he v King b7
and after King 2d6 the key move here is
to not take the pawn but rather play E
754 moves you take the pawn and if the
King keeps going back and forth you keep
going back and forth with your king or
even the bishop from here
actually simplest for black would be to
just bounce back and forth on these two
squares for forever
and it will be a drop
the trick however at this moment right
here is when the king is on d6 you don't
take the pawn but rather push and this
deflects the king away so that now when
you take the pawn you will be able to
next get out of the pawns way and then
promote soon just two moves we're not
quite done with the solution because we
have one other key variation to cover
and that is after the e5 move suppose
Bishop b2 is not played suppose black
doesn't try to get on this diagonal
suppose the bishop captures the pun
now what's going to happen if king takes
Bishop King g3 King d6 king f4 we have
this little race towards the corner and
what's going to happen is it will be a
draw king 8 king c8 the king can never
get out of this pawns way so what's the
trick to this one some of you have
probably already noted what the trick is
the trick is to not take the bait
don't take the bishop instead King e6 is
the key move in this wonderful study
what's the point well this bishop will
be getting in the way of the King in
black will not be winning this race to
the corner now the bishop is simply
useless the King gets over here picks up
the pawn goes to b7 and there's nothing
you can do to stop this the King really
wants to make use of this Square too bad
the bishops in the way got to go around
and you're just one tempo short from
boxing the King in the corner
the bishop just cannot stop this pond
from promoting
what a cool study I really like studies
like this because you could kind of see
an application in regular games you know
this kind of a structure in situations
where you know what even having a bishop
is just not going to be good enough if
you have a superior King position this
King will be able to hunt the pawn down
get out of the pawns way and then be
able to push through and this this pawn
here kind of gets in the way Bishop
can't control a seven so yeah an
interesting study to say the least the
key move here the one that really
captured my attention of course the star
move of this composition is yeah we
could very easily scoop the bishop up on
our way to the corner but he's pretty
much poison we say no thank you and he
eventually obstructs the Kings a little
race to the corner
anyhow as usual feel free to leave any
feedback to this composition in the
comment section below and I hope you
enjoyed it maybe even took a little a
little bit of Education away from this
one that's all for now take care bye
you